saskatchewan's largest city currently has no doctors or clinics accepting patients
doctors say a primary health care crisis has long been looming in Saskatoon
now if you search for a doctor on the Saskatchewan Health Authority database
it comes up blank
people shared their stories with us
some say they've been searching for a doctor for months
others for years
and these anecdotes aren't just isolated to Saskatoon
people all over the province are facing the same issue
and even broader than that
all over Canada
recently a doctor with the Red Cross was deployed to one of these shortages
he wrote a piece for CBC
here in Saskatchewan
doctors say the system needs reform
family doctors are paid on a fee for service model
that means that the number of patients they see directly impacts how much money they make
many don't want to open a practice because it's like opening a business
meanwhile doctors at hospitals are paid by the hour
they also don't have to pay for rent utilities insurance
staff and supplies for a clinic.
without access to family doctors
many are turning to walk in clinics emergency rooms and urgent care centres
some of those centres are now seeing a thousand more patients every month
leaving many waiting hours for care
not having a doctor is also bad for your health
studies have shown that people with a family physician
tend to live longer than people without one
but what's the solution?
doctors say even if they were paid differently there still wouldn't be enough of them
some suggest a team based approach in clinics with pharmacists
nurses and other health care providers on hand to assist with patient needs
what do you think?
what can be done to address this doctor shortage?